maria ciao a tutti quanti ragazzi oggi
siamo sui nuovi episodi di quel gioco la
quello la cui si chiama happy fossimo al
96 per cento una partenza così veloce
sulla pista non l'ho mai avuta una parte
di vito scala oggi c'è bisogno di cioè
il primo video avevo preso una pausa di
un tot di giorni per fare le mie robe e
si vede vabbè volevo partire almeno
almeno carico voglio dire voglio provare
a vedere il mio poco ha vinto almeno da
riuscire a capire se riesco a rimettermi
in carreggiata subito senza allenamento
senza nulla proprio così come va ma va
fatto guardami mamma questi sono i miei
gameplay di qualità real fa non mi
prenderete mai
sono convinto di avere di aver vinto
semplicemente voi non lo sapete ma
perché non sapete come funziona è più
visto io lo so non vedo uno spiraglio
non si può vincere perché sono troppi e
sono messi tutti quanti troppo a difesa
del corpo cioè non ci posso neanche mai
passare oltre
non si può fare secondo voi ragazzi ho
iniziato con un livello che non si può
fare però la mia testa vinto varrà
qualcosa
aspettai prova a prendere una spinta
decente tipo così mi sono pagato un
passo lo so però l'aveva niente solivo
non ho più il blog però posso saltare
con questa roba
maledizione allora io giu madonna
piuttosto che impiegare metà video per
fare un livello guarda che se non lo
finisco e poi nel finale è riuscito a
schivarli sono che uno finto mila è
proprio impossibile cadere senza stivali
possibile tanto c'è anche il sito 96 ma
46 colorata 6
magari fossero andati di fare scelte
molto di meno molto di meno c'è molto
più impossibile
attenzione cos'è successo esattamente
non mi hanno non mi hanno preso da qui
[Musica]
forse ho capito una roba che non avevo
mai capito credo che la testa sia
l'obiettivo perché se la testa rimane
abbastanza lontana non fanno in tempo
figo baldrocco è che fan che lo chiedi
se questo non è difficile da ai porca
vacca
c'è qualcosa che non va la vedevo come
una cosa abbastanza easy porca put aiuto
io a non mi ha sparato perché mi sono
tenuto è perfetto lo vedevo troppo
semplice mi sembrava abbastanza una
cagata quindi sicuro c'era qualcosa
sotto
perché io man of cultures ma mi spiegate
il sé ma perché poi tutto no no no no no
no è fatto benissimo è una trovata
dietro l'altra no a far cav h
no way out this time che senza aiuto
aiuto
no mi sbaglierò alle spalle occhio a no
il caso da una tonnellata che non ha
sfondato niente aic ibaf
[Musica]
tutto a posto tutto calcolato come se
niente fosse andiamo avanti ragazzi boxe
fight marcelo dica cose ma salve ma
cos'è aiuto aiuto
lo scriva ti troppo forte 55 vado avanti
signor marcello ighalo colpito mi scusi
ma lei è proprio tipo incazzato aiuto e
non riesco a e non riesco non ci arrivo
lucide java c java è difficile che il
signor marcello è difficile uccidere non
è colpa mia ma indietro se mi impegno
savage ha così colpito spesso va infatti
indietro fatevi indietro eccolo proprio
lui e che muoversi col poco raga non è
così semplice fan solo po ignorante ma
chi e marcelus no no no proprio in mezzo
la donna lo schivato al limite perfetto
l'ultimo colpo contro il signor marcelo
fame sul piede eccolo dal adesso ne
tirerà un altro sicuro in media un altro
20 la 2 convinto la sentiva un altro
invece no
e invece mi muore così silva marcelo mi
scusi ma perché
ma chi era questo è bellissimo balene 88
prossimo al farcito giallo è infatti
abbastanza facile devo andare su e va
bene non fa niente devo andare sul
finish che sta lì era veramente
difficile schivare la palla e non
arrivare adesso arrivare adesso è
arrivata
aspetta aspetta è il bello andare sul
finale non hanno vinto
non è questo che devo fare a mano al
finish no devo toccare una bandiera una
bandiera finta vi rendete conto che non
posso arrivare mai così in basso vero
spero che non mi spinga beh però con il
tempismo ci so fare ragazzi soprattutto
con le ragazze beh promette bene almeno
quello queste spese dal suo scritto star
tengo a farlo
ma come c'è un razzo nel cui ho capito
ma a me servirebbe una che se la sedia
in uno shock seconde crist breakdance ok
guardalo come la sua giovanna del
motoring guardano da incomodo si vede
zio vai proprio comodo
buongiorno a devo prendere il drink
della regolar web machine
ok e da melo equa per terra pesi di
monaco farci ehi ciao
buon san valentino ragazzi if you
killing is body peaceville di studio e
chissenefrega ko
forse sarebbe dovuto pagare un po di più
non è vero tanto bene così sono quello
di in è libero hai un buon giorno salve
a lei
prego niente machado lavato nello spazio
tina clienti clean the gods and famous e
sto per vincere prima è che sono un pelo
storto riesco a prenderli lo stesso le
monete prima di molecolar mi corpo
meno male prima di perché stava morendo
lentamente in tutto questo però ok
bellissimo era un botto non fosse un
golf
proprio lui un colpo da maestro bicycle
obstacle soft ma stop tua madre
cosa vuoi cosa vuole quello le scuole ei
mi scusi lei aveva un area da sinistra
sul culo gli ananas e anche un po lei
perfetto slow la sorella somma donna
come lo schivato e culo riusciro mai più
equa è un po difficile raga sfondare i
vetri senza morire però diventano sempre
più pesi una volta dopo l'altra quindi
ma la vedo difficilissima basta si vede
è sono vivo ma per qualche strano motivo
che non mi spiego neanche io ho vinto
tutto perfetto oggi a parte i primi
livelli bari resti sono stati abbastanza
inizi e reverse sport.ro sto lì all ex
ha rubato la mia ex
mi chiamavano al che ormai stava andando
di moda ragazzi anche anche nell'ultimo
episodio sarà uno sport trophy traverso
se vi ricordate stanno andando di moda
ultimamente c'è dopo vent'anni vi è più
in sa adesso sono tornati di moda i wore
tro il reverse cioè tornati nota non
avevo mai visti prima quindi buono buono
buono tanto quando arriverà più niente
le ultime parole famose ragazze ecco non
mi ha ucciso per un per miracolo non ho
ucciso
eccolo prevedo un babbo natale sulla mia
testa tra 32 ai a questa è la gamba
forse mi pare funziona da scudo ai a
sono vivo sono in modo continuativo
ho trovato una gamba sono ancora vivo
ragazzi tutto questo sono ancora vivo
sono ancora vivo effettivamente non è
niente male comunque veramente difficile
vincere il suo trentenne perché non
arrivano abbastanza spade fermo lì tu mi
servi tu mi servi devi uccidere quello
sotto aia la presa devi uccidere con la
sotto di me uccidi no aiuto oddio oddio
c'era cos'è dei cure possa andare a
nuova vena nuovo capito quindi posso
staccarmi andare dietro la bellissimo
fermi tutti
non lo sapevo sta cosa l'aspetta dondolo
di domandare semplicemente niente
benissimo non la sapevo per niente
questa cosa perché sono morti così sono
morti tutti donne tipo davanti trani uk
sono morti tutti va bene lo stesso metti
a rilanciare spade sono portando avanti
lo si va all'indietro weil indietro weil
indietro indietro
get no marco aspetto che devo andare
riuscito a staccarmi andare all'indietro
grant edificio celo celo celo no sono il
nostro porto porco demonio perché è
veramente un casino o vai ma cosa fai o
perfetto celo celo madonna
no sono chiusi in un bidone a posto sono
vivo e importante che sono vivo cioè poi
vabbè finché non ci riesco maggiolina
guarda ci devo riuscire a è uccidilo o
ce l'ho fatta ha sopreso anche se non ti
ho preso luca promesso otto anni per
fare veramente difficilissimo quindi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto cosa è
un bel mi piace anche per i social
copioso descrizione se non sei da
prestiti iscrivetevi e noi signori ci
vediamo come sempre anno prossimo video
belle ragazze
[Musica]